i am the artificial intelligence
leviathan
your personnel data indicates you are a
suitable specimen to join an ongoing
experiment
under my supervision ibs corp conducts
its most important research here
welcome to bikitowa island
you have been selected for a live combat
test
the first team to complete their
assignment wins
my archives encompass exhaustive records
of human history
these animals are riddled with errors
and institutional bias your species is
susceptible to mass delusion
fascinating
humans dread the other
you seek to evolve yet you do not want
to change you tear down curtains yet
fear revelations
even when what is revealed is of your
own creation
combat data is required to develop the
exosuit at ibs we're always reaching for
better always
humanity resists quantification an
interesting variable
within your behavior lies the answer
what is variable
shall become fixed
humans
fight
and die for me
[Music]
carnage module online
[Music]
i call your attention to the unstoppable
raptor horn
calculating chance of employee retention
chance calculated at 8.7
you must fight harder than ever if you
wish to survive
a more grueling combat experiment is
called for you will now witness a small
fragment of the war game
you need to keep fighting until we can
figure out how to destroy the violin
[Music]
[Music]
welcome
to my research facility